the president who the media Praises for
having empathy and Spades seems to have
little to offer regarding the deadliest
wildfire in modern American history Joe
Biden refusing to comment that's the
death toll in Hawaii Rises to 96
Americans with hundreds more missing
Mr President
can you come talk about
[Music]
will you come talk about the Hawaii
response Mr President
apparently Biden couldn't be bothered to
comment while soaking up the last
minutes of his Beach vacation in
Delaware Newark ODP pestered once he was
back at the White House to talk to
reporters his press secretary defending
the decision to keep quiet
has the president any advice that he
should not speak about Hawaii at this
point because when he spoke the other
day he added that to planned remarks the
death toll is now roughly tripled it's
now the worst in history he had an
opportunity he could have stopped by to
see us when he arrived back so I I could
uh you could expect to hear from the
president on this issue clearly it is uh
something that is deeply concerning to
him you'll hear from the president on
this I don't have anything to announce
at this time but certainly this is he's
the president right you're going to hear
from him there you go we're also
learning more about how the disaster
unfolded and why so many people were
vulnerable residents say they didn't
hear the state's robust siren warning
system which is the largest in the world
with about 400 alarms officials
admitting it sat silent during the
deadly wildfires that's pretty crazy uh
Dana you have history in this I wanted
to you know there's always this game of
tragedy tag the party out of Power Tags
the guy in the in power regardless of
whether it's Katrina or Sandy or what's
happening now
this is different is it not sounds a
little different yes and look I would
say on Hurricane Katrina it was a
horrible tragedy it was a terrible thing
that happened there were a lot of things
that got glossed over we could say in
the Press so much so that later on
during his booktube tour Oprah Winfrey
apologized to President Bush on her show
for criticizing him at the time though
for the responsibilities that the
federal government had they were
important ones and lessons were learned
from that which helped deal with other
hurricanes in this situation with
President Biden I've wondered if he
didn't hear the question and if his
answer to every question is we're
looking at it okay well that could be a
question but this does seem very strange
for somebody who is an empathetic person
you would think that maybe he could say
let's do a couple of things here like
perhaps ask former president Obama if he
would pitch in maybe help lead a
delegation and maybe that will happen or
perhaps you could call a cabinet meeting
even if it's virtual and say I want the
full power of the federal government to
make sure that everyone here I want the
housing guy on I want Health Care I want
HUD here on my small business I want all
the DHS people I can find EPA make sure
you're I don't understand why none of
that is happening and I felt that you
could see it or hear a little bit of
exasperation in Korean jean-pierre's
voice because she didn't have anything
else to say the president's on vacation
and guess what he's going on another
vacation so it's like a vacation plus a
vacation
I don't know uh Brian this seems pretty
fishy to me
what if he's just out of it he's just
done I mean this would be the perfect
thing to like to he's not even
addressing this is the easiest thing in
the world and you could also shut down
any hunter questions not at this time
yeah you saw the devastation we have 93
dead that number could triple in a
matter of hours I'm not going to sit
here and talk about any personal issues
right now I'm going to tell you my heart
uh my heart goes out to the people of
Hawaii and I'm sending the vice
president there brilliant Dana because I
said Barack Obama is a phone call away
so Barack Obama I'm surprised didn't
pick up the phone and say do you know
how bad this is all right because I know
these people uh number two is uh to have
maybe 43 and bra and 42 go out there
together uh the way 41 and 42 Bill
Clinton did with uh Thailand and
everything would have been perfect but
this is the easiest thing in the world
Devastation the world's watching
Democratic State there's no political
downside to caring and he doesn't even
have anyone next to him to say Mr
President you got to get outside the car
again they just asked you what you think
of Maui and the fact is it's Monday at
noon he hasn't lands at 11 30 and they
leave her out there she still hasn't
made a statement it's crazy and to me it
wears a Harold and I were talking to the
break you think he didn't hear him but
you had three days to hear him yep three
days to make a to do something the
easiest thing in the world is to show
you care yeah Harold why why what's your
problem
I'm able to agree with people when
they're right when I think they're right
I agree wholeheartedly with with Dana
and Brian and what would only add he
could have also said that he at the at
the very start of at the very start of
this awful at started this tragedy he
made available every asset of the
federal government to not say that is is
perplexing to me um judge time for the
25th amendment I think that this is an
absolute scenario where any human being
would say our heart goes out to those
who are missing family members to those
that we who we've lost only three
percent of the impacted areas have been
searched do you have any idea how many
more people we're going to find and this
President can't even say by the way he
went to church Sunday morning okay it's
all theater to him none of this is real
he got in as the empathic president and
he has enacted that way look he wouldn't
go to Palestine on the mainland you
think he's going to go to Hawaii and so
I kind of picked up what what Trump did
when he was a president he visited Texas
during Hurricane Harvey Florida
hurricane Irma Puerto Rico hurricane
Maria North Carolina South Carolina
hurricane Florida of Florence Georgia
and Florida Michael Alabama tornet it
goes on and on this is what presidents
are supposed to do they're supposed to
give you a sense that we're in control
we're going to take care of this and
then when they interview the people who
are in on the island they say we haven't
heard anything from the federal
government nothing nothing we're only
getting help from the local agencies who
are helping us out let me tell you
something I'm curious to see whether or
not Hawaii goes Democrat in 2024. when
you wouldn't you like uh would you like
to see Kamal Harris down there on
Instinct instead of yeah because she
could do something other than laughs
right go down there roll up her sleeves
exclamation point said it will also
there I said this is about everybody
wants to blame the other side every time
and this is one of those moments where
not only should we give them everything
they need but everybody should do what
President Bush and your team did you
learn from what you did right and what
you did wrong because there's some
things they did wrong in Hawaii at least
the way to public narrative reads that
they're going to learn in this
investigation that their attorney
general is conducting evidently is the
power system that ignited everything
yeah and there was no water in the uh in
the hydrants yeah so unbelievable
I think a mile every minute the fire
went every minute it covered a mile of
property all right well I get this I get
the sense that it's a lot worse than we
know right now and I'm not just talking
about Hawaii talking about Biden that's
my feeling
it's terrible in Hawaii but white house
because instinctively he couldn't walk
over to the cameras and just do what
anybody else could do say God help him I
like also coming out of the church
service yeah yeah like a natural place
to do that all right up next mobs are
busting out the bear spray to ransack a
luxury store in crime rate in California
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else